initially um
doing that first tape with jeezy was
that like um did you guys have an
organic relationship
was it like was how did that like
how did that initially start so the
house the crib that he's talking about
532 glen iris in the fourth ward um
our neighbor around the corner was coach
k
okay so we met coach um when we moved
into the neighborhood
and he befriended us early and we
befriended each other
he had this group called jadis um bobby
creekwater was actually in a group we
wound up
signing to shady right to shady up um
and then you know we were all huh
slick fuller slick puller oh for real oh
okay so stick with slick
yeah yeah he was one of the original
rappers too
so then we um you know coach was telling
us about
you know just this new artist he had and
jeezy's
first project was actually called come
shop with me and he had this video yeah
i remember seeing that he's like in new
jersey
i remember buying it from when it used
to sound like trick daddy wow and then
so we knew so yeah it was it was pretty
organic
um you know he came he came to me and we
like
we met at this restaurant called harry
and sons and you know we um
he pretty much showed me it told me his
whole vision like this you know
the streets is really [ __ ] with your
drawing like you know i don't even know
if you realize how much the streets is
[ __ ] with you and
you know he told me it's the movement in
the campaign and
um yeah it was it was definitely it was
really organic i mean even
interestingly enough you know it's
atlanta too so you know lake was running
into carbon 15
um early in the game
yeah telling me yeah i got my man jeezy
and i'd be like huh like what are you
talking about drama be telling me about
it i actually i actually met named two
in a different occasion i was in my dorm
and i used to have a window and my
sit up my dj set up and produce and said
i was in a window
and he used to come and mess with this
shorty that was my next door neighbor
and he ran by my window one time and he
was like you make a beast
fire you know what i'm saying give me
some beats but it never turned into
nothing because i
you know we wanted to meet him a little
later he always reminds me of that by
the way i knew you said
you was making a beat to your [ __ ]
dorm [ __ ] that's crazy did you say that
not too long ago i remember that yeah
he reminds me i didn't remember what he
was talking about yeah i remember seeing
him he's always had bread and i was like
who's this cat bro and i used to look
like i used to come out the door and i
looked
again he had like this 645 some crazy
[ __ ]
like okay that he's something yeah you
know that costs money yeah yeah we wound
up seeing
him a little later and i was like okay
that's the dude and annie used to come
to club envy all the time too
oh yeah that's right his record played
that trick daddy record yeah